okay Bianca is currently a Waterloo
she's got these very exciting sipping
algorithms you have to noon everybody
thank you the organizers for inviting me
so I'll be talking about some provable
sieving algorithms for the shortest
vector problem and the closest vector
problem in the LP norm I'll go quickly
through the first two sections because I
think we all know much about these two
things and preliminary definitions and
introducing the problem and then I'll
talk about the algorithms so as we all
know given M linearly independent
vectors a lattice is an integral
combination of these vectors and here n
is the rank of the lattice and these the
dimension of the lattice if the rank is
equal to the dimension we have a full
rank lattice for example in the figure
below this is not a full rank lattice
these set of independent vectors is
called a basis of the lattice which is
not unique for example the one above is
a basis there are two bases of the there
two lattice and below we'd this is not a
lat this is not a basis of this lattice
so fundamental parallelepiped so given a
basis of lattice a fundamental
parallelepiped is a combination of this
basis vectors where the coefficients lie
between 0 and 1 this depends on the
basis for example this figure shows two
fundamental parallelepiped of the same
lattice and for any Z vector on the real
plane there exists a unique vector in
the fundamental parallelepiped such that
their difference is a lattice vector and
we call this operation as Y congruent to
0 modulo B the translates of this
fundamental parallelepiped they actually
form as partition of the span of this
lattice the ID successive minimum is the
smallest R such that the lattice
contains at least a linearly independent
vectors of length at most R and the
first such minimum is the length of the
shortest nonzero lattice vector which is
also equal to the smallest distance
between any two lattice vectors for
example
these red vectors are the shortest
vector of the lattice okay now in the
shortest vector problem we are given as
input a lattice which is specified by a
basis and the output of this problem
should be a nonzero lattice vector of
the shortest norm or sum or up to some
approximation of the shortest vector for
example in this figure this red this
blue vectors are a basis of this lattice
the red one is the exact shortest vector
of the lattice and this brown one is the
approximate shortest one in a closest
vector problem the input instance
considers consists of a lattice which is
specified by a basis again and a target
vector and the goal is to output a
lattice vector which is closest to this
target either exactly or up to some
approximation factor for example here
the the green one is the target vector
the red vector is the exact shortest
vector to this this green vector and the
brown one is the approximate shot exact
closest vector I'm sorry and the brown
one is the approximate closest vector
okay since we are talking about LP norm
some quick recap about the LP norm of a
vector it is given by this quantity
summation over mod X I go to the power P
total hole to the power 1 by P and in
the L and finish L infinity norm it's
just the maximum of the absolute value
of value of any of the coordinates of
the vector a ball is a set of all points
which is within a fixed distance of
radius from a fixed point or Center for
example in this figure we see a number
of closed balls in L 1 l 2 L 4 and L
infinity norm
okay the applications of SVP and CVP as
we all know by now are various like
factoring polynomials over rationals
checking the solver bt by radicals
solving low density subset-sum problem
script analysis cryptography and integer
programming okay
so first I'll give some quick recap of
some sieving algorithms for SVP and CVP
then I'll discuss some new algorithms
which we have so much of the war
conceiving algorithms have been done in
the Euclidean norm the first such
sieving algorithm randomized sieving
algorithm was given by a Thai Kumar and
she's Shiva Kumar to solve SVP and
approximate CVP and they ran in single
exponential time the fastest sieving
algorithm for SVP for a constant
approximation factor and sin time 2 to
the power zero point eight zero to n
plus smaller n n it was given by Li Wang
Joo and Zheng the fastest provable
algorithm for SVP and CVP is based on
discrete Gaussian sampling it runs in
time and space to the power n plus
smaller and and it has been given by
Agarwal the douche Sri gave Stephens
David agrees the theoretically fastest
heuristic algorithm for SVP e runs in
time 3 by 2 whole to the bearing by 2
and it has been given by Becker dukkha
gamma and laarhoven in the in the non
Euclidean norm Blumer annoy and Arvind
and Jo clicker first generalized the AKS
algorithm to give exact and approximate
algorithms for SVP in the LP norm and
CVP approximate CVP it ran in time to
route the power order n they did not
specify the exact value of the constant
I'll give you this value of this
constant in later slides isin bran and
the others they improved this algorithm
in the L infinity norm so they gave an
algorithm for approximate CVP up to a
factor approximation factor 1 plus if
Silan with our running time which has a
better dependence on this approximation
factor of silence so it ran in time to
do the power order n log 1 by silent
whole to the power n and in a joint work
with Agarwal Devesh Agarwal
we had this result which improved the
running time for this exact and
approximate SVP and CVP approximate CVP
in the L infinity norm I'll talk more
about this algorithm because the LP norm
algorithm is just a generalization of
this algorithm ok some quick recap about
some grease some hardness results for a
3 P and CVP the first NP hardness result
for CVP in the L in LP norm and SVP in
the L infinity norm was given by van M
de bas in 1981 the NP hardness of CVP in
the LP norm and SVP in the Infinity norm
up to a factor n to the
barsy by log log n has been given by de
new Raj Kindler and Safra then havi
vendor gave building on a work by coat
they gave a hardness of SVP in LP norm
for a factor hardness factor of 2 to the
power log in 1 minus Epsilon assuming NP
not a subset of our time n to the power
poly log N and recently I've shown the
hardness of CVP in the LP norm and SVP
in the Infinity norm up to factor
polynomial factored into the power C
where C strictly less than half assuming
the projection games conjecture okay so
in any sieving algorithm usually the
most expensive part the most
time-consuming part is the sieving
iterations so I'll first explain a bit
about the sieving algorithm sieving
procedure and since all these bloomer
and noise sieve which works in the LP
norm is a generally a generalization of
the sieving procedure given by aks so I
call it the aks see so in 1 sieving
iteration we are first given a set of
capital and lattice vectors which are
offer a certain length say maximum
length R so they are all contained
within a ball of radius capital R and
after one iteration we want some shorter
vectors of length say gamma times R
where gamma is strictly less than 1 so
so in a sieving iteration first what we
do is in the aks type of see if we
select a subset of centres so we select
these centres in such a way that the
number of centers should not be too
large because they determine the space
complexity and also we we want them to
we want to select them in such a way
such that for all the rest of the
vectors can be associated with any such
center in such a way that like each such
vector should be within distance gamma R
of any one of the center's so in this
figure the read the read vectors are the
center's and we have drawn a ball of
radius gamma around each of the center's
so we have associated all these vectors
which are within this radius to each
Center then we take the difference of
these vectors so we get a number of
shorter vectors of length say gamma R
and then we discard all the center's so
so so
to a polynomial number of ceiling
operations we expect we get a number of
lattice vectors of norm at most R 0
times lambda 1 where R 0 is some
constant so to give some provable
guarantees on the running time space
complexity or success probability of the
algorithm we we face some issues and one
of the issues is we cannot ensure the
distribution of the vectors after each
sieving step so it might be that we will
end up with all 0 vectors and a solution
is for a sample vector we add a randomly
chosen perturbation vector so to
summarize so what we do is initially so
to summarize the whole see a whole
sieving algorithm and LP norm so
initially we sample a number of
perturbation vectors uniformly from a
ball of radius R 0 and we calculate some
perturbed vectors then we do a number of
sieving iterations so in each sieving
iteration we perform all the operations
on the perturb vectors and these
operations get reflected on the
corresponding lattice vectors so at the
end of all the sieving iterations we
take pairwise difference of all the
vectors in the final set and finally
output the one with the shortest norm so
so we see the complexity of the AKS
sieve is quadratic in the sense that if
we start with capital n vectors we the
time complexity is usually order n
square that's because in each sieving
iteration to associate each vector to a
center we have to compare with all the
center's ok so so this kind of a case
sieving operations can be viewed in a
different way it's like as if we have a
space of vectors and we are subdividing
that space in a number of sub regions
and we are dividing in in such a way
such that the number of sub spaces
should not be large because they
determine the space complexity which
also gets reflected in the time
complexity and we should be able to map
each of the vectors to each sub-region
efficiently so that our time complexity
does not blow up much so to cater to
these problems so the recently I came up
with this linear sieving procedure so
what we do is so in the previous
algorithms we saw that the larger LP
hyper
all has been divided into smaller LP
balls so what we do instead of that we
divide the LP ball into smaller
hypercubes okay so suppose we have a lot
of vectors of within a ball of radius
capital R so we partition the space into
hypercube such that the longest diagonal
has lengths it's a smaller where smaller
is the desired length of the vectors
after one sieving step so this this this
guarantees that the distance between any
two vector within each hypercube is at
most small R and also we can map each
vector to a region this just by looking
at the coordinate so it can be done in
small n plus small of one time and then
we choose at most one Center in each
such hypercube and then we take the
difference now these number of
partitions are hyper cubes they
determine the space complexity and this
can be bounded by this term order 2 plus
2 by gamma whole to the power small n if
this your smaller is gamma times R and
this comes from upper bound on the
number of translates of a hypercube
which is centered at the origin which is
number of translates which are needed to
cover this LP ball so for example in
this l1 norm these are the number of
translates of the hypercube which are
near to cover this l1 ball so this is
the these are the these are this is how
the partitions look in the l2 norm and
in the L infinity norm now to determine
the number of partitions we can look at
it as if we are dividing the each of the
axis into intervals and the number of
partitions we get they depend on how we
divide each axis into intervals okay so
for example so this is one kind of
partition we get of the L infinity ball
if we take the starting hypercube
somewhere near the center we could have
also taken the hypercube in at one
corner and then we can get a different
partition and we actually get a number
much less number of partitions in this
way so we get order 2 by gamma whole to
the power n ok so we see after this
procedure that our space complex
increases a bit but our time complexity
is much better if we compare with the
existing algorithm so this is the space
and time complexity of bloomer and noise
algorithm they did not give any I mean
they did not calculate this constants
this constants have been calculated by
me after incorporating the same kind of
optimizations which I did for my linear
sieving proceeding algorithm so they
have a time complexity of 2 to the power
3 point 8 4 n and that's the time
complexity of linear series 2 to the
power 2 0.751 n which is better but our
space complexity is worse than theirs in
the Euclidean norm we have a better time
complexity compared to the AKS sieve
which the curtain complexity come
calculated by hand review all and still
in they have a time complexity 2 to the
power 2 point 5 7 1 and we have a time
complexity of 2 to the power 2 point 4
and n but again our space complexity is
worse in the L infinity norm we have a
space and time complexity of 2 to the
power 2 point 4 4 3 n plus small Owen by
till now I've to the best of my
knowledge this is the fastest now to
take advice also what we see now in the
quadratic sieving procedure we have an
advantage that our space complexity is
less and in the linear safe our space
complexity increases but the time
complexity reduces so you can get the
best of both walls we can combine these
two procedures what we do so suppose we
have we start with this bigger ball
bigger hyper hyper ball where we have
all the vectors then we divide this
region into a somewhat bigger hyper
cubes of sum where the length of the
longest diagonal is say R dash then
within each hypercube we do a quadratic
sieving procedure so what we get after
doing this is we get some improvement
over the linear sieving procedure so for
example if we compare with the list safe
birthday algorithm so the lists if
birthday algorithm has a time complexity
of 2 to the power 2 point 4 6 5 and the
smaller end and this is the time
complexity as calculated by hand righto
called stelae of the algorithm of the
list sieve algorithm which was actually
given by Machine Show and vulgaris and
we have a somewhat better time
complexity to do the part
point to five n plus smaller n but our
space complexities worse but again both
our space and type space and time
complexity is worse than the fastest
approve will have guard them till now
which was given by Agarwal each and the
do should I gave and Steve Stevens David
obese they have a space and time
complexity to the power N and this kind
of mixed saving algorithm actually has
the maximum advantage in the Euclidean
norm so we can also we can also modify
our algorithms to get some approximate
approximation algorithms for large
constant approximation factor the
procedure is very simple I'm not going
to the details we just skip the last
step of the exact algorithm so we sample
receive and we return a non zero vector
and we get an algorithm for CVP by using
this reduction from approximate CVP to
approximate SVP ok so by doing this we
see that we have an approximate
algorithm which has a time complexity to
to the power nearly 2n which is better
than the algorithm by bloomer and noise
they have a time complexity to to the
power three point 1 6 n and again our
space complexities worse in the
Euclidean norm we don't gain much our
both space and time complexity is much
better than the fastest algorithm till
now they have a time complexity 2 to the
power zero point eight zero to n and
ours is two to the power one point seven
three n plus smaller in some large
constant approximation factor is the
smaller m and the L in the L infinity
norm the space and time complexity is
two to the power one point five eight
five n plus small Owen
so we have time for questions
yes what was this reduction for
approximate nice this isn't bloomer and
no I don't know about this yeah this is
this is this was a reduction which was
given by bloomer anoi which which is
like a reduction from approximate CVP to
approximate SVP in the LP norm so using
any which runs in polynomial time so we
can use any Oracle for approximate as VP
and solve the proximate CVP observation
factor in the CVP is is 1 plus if silent
something like it's it's not a an
exponential time thing okay any other
question
okay let's think brown again
[Applause]